Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sama Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sama Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sama Sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
The purpose of this little talk really is to make sure that we're all fairly clear as to what the Buddha means by right awareness.
Right awareness.
And I always think it's good to just go over a little bit of his biography, which makes it, I think, more plain to us.
So remember he was brought up in an aristocratic family.
Later tradition, of course, builds him up into this huge kingship and all that sort of stuff.
But basically, his father was a vassal to the local king.
And his people were just part of that empire at the top, well, kingdom at the top of India, which borders Nepal.
But being of that caste, the Kshatriya caste, the warrior caste, his education would have been mainly about flashy swords and shields and stuff like that.
and maybe a bit of astrology yeah things like that wouldn't be any cooking or you know domestic stuff so we can presume that he lived a fairly happy life really sensually anyway just getting what he wants things like that somewhere in his 20s he gets married
and round about 29 he leaves his wife and newborn child for us of course that sounds terrible desertion but you have to remember it was an extended family it wasn't as though his wife was out on the street but if somebody does that if somebody leaves a home the people they love then one presumes that there is something
very urgent in that need.
And we can only presume that he had what we would call an existential crisis.
So remember, it's put in that mythological sense that as he's taken out to do some hunting, he comes across a very sick person, a very old person, a corpse, and an ascetic sitting under a tree.
so they're called messengers from the gods and what the myth is trying to tell us is that somewhere in his mid-twenties he came out of youth and realized that in fact what he was heading for was sickness old age and death and that can come as a shock to some people so this realization that all the effort we put in life everything we do
personally just ends up with just a load of ashes scattered here and there and that basic meaninglessness of life so in his day of course it would have been also included in this idea of rebirth or reincarnation which meant that having done all that which was completely meaningless ending up as a pile of ashes he'd have to do it all over again and all over again
and over again it just seemed to be a ceaseless process of life after life going through this same routine and that was partly the despair of the age and it was mirrored in a lot of people moving out of the lay life into some sort of aesthetic practice and there were many other religious teachers perhaps the other famous one was
and he can't be the person who founded the James China he was a contemporary the book so when he left I found a bit like the hippies in the sixties you left everything to sex drugs and rock and roll just like different purpose but even so so we have to imagine that he's in a pretty turbulent mental state when he leaves home and
He's put mythologically, of course, as in the dark night.
You know, he leaves on his horse, Cantica, with his servant.
And he goes to the river, crosses the river, you see.
You know, the Rubicon.
And change of life, cuts his hair off, all that sort of stuff.
And even his horse dies of grief.
Can you imagine?
It's a terrible time.
So now he's left what we would call the sensual life, the life of pleasure.
consumerist life and what drives him there is the essential sense of uselessness about it the vapid uselessness of sensual pleasure if you're seeking true happiness everlasting happiness so the first thing he does is he joins teachers who show him how to establish
very beautiful states of mind, blissful states.
And this you'll find in all religions, the ecstasies.
And the great thing about jhana, the absorptions, as we call them, is that you don't need anything at all once you can access them.
So last night we did a little bit of metta practice.
So just by repeating that gently over and over, there's a sort of draw inward, and the heart begins to respond.
And there's a lovely beauty comes to it, and the body feels good.
And as you draw inward to that, you leave the body into a beautiful state of the inner mind.
And you can stay there.
So all you need is a loincloth and a bit of food.
You need a little bowl, hang about, go and get your porridge, come back, sit under a tree, and get blissed out all day.
And the problem with that, he found, was of course, when he came out of it, he was still the depressed, anxious Siddhartha Gautama.
So even though he now found a joy which was far superior to the ordinary transient pleasures of life, something you could really maintain within yourself, and when you become an adept, you could just click into it, just settle down, and in you went into this inner ecstasy.
there was this sense of uselessness again, because eventually you came out of it.
So it wasn't eternal, and it was, although it wasn't based on anything outside yourself, it was based on some technique, some ability within yourself.
So he had two teachers, and both of them took him to a point where they actually invited him to come and teach with them, yeah?
but he hadn't really solved this gnawing problem in his heart concerning the meaninglessness of life that true existential angst so the next thing he tries are mortification exercises and for this he was obviously influenced by the Neaganther the Jain founder the Jains have
sort of idea that the jiva the soul is weighed down by these clumps of chewing gum karmic clumps so when you do something wrong it's like a it's like a splodge on your soul and it keeps it weighted down and the way to get rid of it was through these heavy mortification exercises and all these splodges fell off and the soul rose to the highest heaven so it's very sort of material
a very concrete idea of what happened and of course there's a truth in it that once our defilements disappear then of course we enter into a very beautiful state and the idea was or the understanding was that the problem was the body so you wouldn't have greed if you didn't feed your hunger if you let go of all sex
and you just denied your body then you wouldn't have any lust so the idea of the ascetic life was to deny the body to draw it down to an essential just bones and a bit of muscle and keep yourself away from the world and in which sense everything would finally just drop off and the Jain saint is one who starts themselves to death by which time of course they're not attached to anything
And they also understood the role of desire.
So that was fairly, you know, that was coming through from the Brahminical tradition too, the idea of that the problem was desire.
Socrates understood that, that the problem was this desire, this attachment to things.
So he tried these exercises, and he talks of himself being able to hold his spine through his stomach.
Have you tried that?
So he got thin, really thin.
But unfortunately, he still ended up being miserable.
So there came a point where he realized this wasn't taking him anywhere either.
He almost killed himself, you could say.
So at that point, he leaves his companions, his five companions.
So now we can only presume that he's in a state of despair because
he's gone out with this real hope of finding an end to this inner suffering that he has this inner meaninglessness of life and he's tried all these famous teachers and he's almost killed himself with these mortification exercises and he's still stuck he still hasn't answered this deep inner problem so one can only presume that he's feeling pretty wretched standing on the roadside now you
Some of you will know that Sujata comes with an offering of rice pudding for the local god.
It's actually rice cakes, but I much prefer rice pudding.
And seeing this poor wretch, she offers it to him, you see.
In the literature, you'll see that he's shining like a god, and she mistakes him for a god, but basically he's pretty miserable.
And eating this stuff revives him, you see.
Now, shortly after that time, and this is why we call him
self-enlightened, he has a memory.
And the memory concerns, as a child, watching his father doing a ploughing ceremony.
So this is to open the ploughing season.
And he remembers the state he was in while he's watching his father doing this ploughing ceremony.
And the state he's in is an absorption state, but it's also full of inquiry.
It's full of curiosity.
It's the first time he's really
become aware of this ceremony.
Okay?
And he's a child.
At this point, his whole practice turns around on itself.
He's no longer trying to escape suffering by finding some other heavenly state.
He now turns upon suffering and asks the question, how does suffering arise in the first place?
And it's with that new inspiration that he goes to sit under a tree.
he sees no other way apart from this particular attack and he determines to sit there either to crack this problem or die lucky for him lucky for us he cracks it in a mere six hours and from that point on something has deeply changed within him his relationship to the world has been completely turned around
So now let's just go back a step and just consider this state that he remembers from childhood, okay?
So if we take anybody under six, under seven, that sort of age, when you see a child looking at something they've not seen before, like a beetle or something, their eyes become fixed on it, they even stop blinking, yeah?
The jaw drops and they look gormless, yeah?
And they're completely fixated on it.
There's no thought in the mind because they can't describe it.
There's no concept to attach to it.
And then when it's completely absorbed, they turn around and say, what is it?
And the beautiful parent says, that's a beetle.
From that point on, that child never sees a beetle again.
Because every time we see a beetle...
we put the experience of all past beetles onto that beetle.
In other words, the life that we lead are constantly being distorted by concepts, by our history.
In order to find this path to the end of suffering, we have to go back to that mental state.
We have to go back to the original mind, that's what Zen calls it, the original mind of the child.
And that is our difficulty.
Our difficulty is to draw this intelligence, the Buddha within, this intelligence, to draw it out of its confusion with the intellect.
And all meditation techniques are trying to make us do that.
That's the prime object.
All this stuff about mindfulness and constant attention, concentration, all that sort of stuff, is all subservient
to the point of trying to purify this intelligence we have this intuitive intelligence so for instance in this technique and I'll go into it in more detail this evening the idea of using a single word is at least to draw the intellect down to a singular concrete concept rising, falling there's no thinking around it see
And at that level, it's possible to draw this intelligence directly into the experience that's happening, which is at the level of sensation of feeling.
And whatever techniques you've practiced, you'll see that the whole technique always draws you back to your body, back to your sense base.
Because it's there that you begin to rediscover this way of looking at things.
and the practice of that quiet abiding that we do is to clarify that awareness an awareness which is not engaging which is completely open just like the child's mouth dropped just like its eyes fixed just receiving just receiving and it's only within when that has been established do we bring in this quality of curiosity
and it's an open curiosity, it's the curiosity of a cat it mustn't come from any expectation or any ideas it's just a complete state of curiosity best coming from a position of don't know don't know so that's what we mean by right awareness in terms of its quality but this curiosity, remember
has already been shall we say educated to look at certain things and that's where the three characteristics come in so if you're going to anybody who's into science anybody who's into nature an artist they all have to develop that open-mindedness again or else they just repeat the whole point about an original artist is that they see the world differently
and to do that they have to drop all the art that they've learnt before a philosopher has to drop all past philosophy in order to see in a new way a scientist has to investigate not from the point of view of what has already been discovered but from what has not been discovered it's the new question it's the new way of looking at things that brings discovery but even so
there is that scientific knowledge there is that philosophical knowledge and there is all the artistry sitting as it were behind supporting the looking so with us it's the Buddha Dhamma and especially the teaching around impermanence the role of desire as the cause of psychological suffering and the fact that nothing has any substance nothing's real that you can't point to something and say
This is real, this is me.
Because every time you hold on to something that's me, it's constantly disappearing.
So we understand that and it lies, as it were, underneath the looking.
We're not thinking about it.
We're not bringing it into the practice.
It's there.
It's already there because we've been taught to look like that.
And so when we sit, we put all that to the side.
At the end of last night's
instructions I said putting all instruction aside so you use your instructions you use your techniques to get yourself primed to a point where you're just observing just feeling just experiencing what's drawing your attention within the field of awareness it's simply that and it's the simplicity which foxes us we're looking for something a little bit cleverer than that something a bit more demanding
so as long as we understand that in our practice we keep bringing ourselves back to that simplicity then slowly but surely that original mind begins to manifest much more obviously to us and we know when we're in it and we know when we're not in it now the other thing is of course to bring that same sense of mindfulness into daily life so this morning we were talking about work about actually bringing it into everything we do
when we're conversing with each other when we're thinking about something like planning our holiday or something when we're doing something so obviously there it's a different type of awareness the awareness now is in to action is now in to doing before it was abstracted it had found this observation post within ourselves but now it has to re-enter
He has to re-enter the psychophysical organism, his body, mind and heart, and through it into the world.
And once that happens, the idea is not so much to be observing ourselves, but to have still that wide open awareness, so that we are also aware of not only what we're doing, but what we're feeling.
So that we know, for instance, when we meet somebody, we feel a high degree of irritation and hatred.
See?
On the surface of things, I may be presenting a very kind, lovable, huggable person.
You see?
But inside, I'm just, I want to strangle the person.
So here I am, not getting caught up in either, but putting my attention more in the process of observing.
When I'm at work,
and outwardly I'm doing my work very well and it's all very diligent and all that inwardly I'm utterly and completely bored and I'm aware of that you see somehow I can stand above it I can be with the boredom and yet pay attention to what I'm doing and come from a different place a place of wisdom a place of compassion whereby I can actually put my energy into the right intention
And I can only do that if I can dissociate from, disidentify from this boredom, from this irritation, from this depression, from this anxiety.
As soon as I drop into an identity, I am bored, then who's going to get me out of that?
As soon as I say, I am depressed, that's it, I'm stuck, I'm depressed.
See?
so the whole point of this meditation is to continue that sense of objectivity within us not suppressing it you see not pushing it aside not turning away from it but allowing it to express itself at that level of awareness somewhere within that field but my attention is on what I'm supposed to be doing and with that attention there comes an intention whenever I place my attention
It must be an act of intention.
And that's what's conditioning me.
So every time I start a job, every time I meet somebody, every time I go to work, every time I come to sit, there has to be just that moment of inward gazing.
There has to be a sort of global awareness of both what's outside and inside.
And then having recognized it, I can make,
skillful decision as to what I'm going to do so that's the distinction between this vipassana which is about investigating these three characteristics and mindfulness in order daily life and what that draws us to as the Buddha says is clear comprehension that's his his phrase for mindfulness clear comprehension so when you're stretching your arm you know you're stretching your arm when you don't mean the fridge you know you're opening the fridge
When you're closing the fridge, you know you're closing the fridge.
In other words, you're not walking out of the kitchen and slamming the fridge behind you.
You're not from here, when the bell goes to the lunch, your mind is not already in the dining room and your body catches up 10 minutes afterwards.
Your mind knows that it's going to the dining room, but your attention is right on your footsteps.
And it's that knowledge of where you're going somewhere in the future
but bringing yourself constantly back to what is actually happening in the present moment.
So that distinction has to be made.
If not, then you might make the mistake of always trying to observe yourself at all times of the day.
And that just drives you potty, frankly.
On the other hand, you might think, well, when I'm meditating, I'm trying to create something.
I'm trying to see these three characteristics.
So that's wrong effort.
You have to have a certain faith that there is within us this quality, this Buddha nature, call it what you wish, which is constantly seeking its own liberation.
That's what's suffering.
And it's constantly seeking its own liberation, constantly seeking understanding.
And it's crying out constantly all the time, get that meditator out of the way.
See?
so as soon as you see yourself trying to do something trying to see trying to attain then turn on it and say you're the meditator get out of the way see and then start again start again now during the day you see you can practice this this open awareness as you walk around the grounds for instance and just put your attention on a flower you see and
See how the mind immediately tries to position it, what type of flower it is, describing it, how wonderful it is, right?
Let all that pass, let all that pass, just keep the eye on the flower, right?
And just be aware of the process of perception.
How is the eye seeing the flower, right?
Not what you think about it, whether you've seen one before and all that rubbish, just how is the eye seeing the flower?
When you sit out there, when you're walking out there,
or sitting actually, we might walk into something, and you close your eyes and you start listening, right?
Just see how the mind wants to know what bird it is and where it is, all right?
And just let that go and just put your attention entirely on the process of hearing.
What is it you're actually hearing?
Okay?
In this way, you're constantly drawing this intelligence out of its confusion with the intellect, confusion with history, see?
And it's very simple to do it because all you have to do is relax.
Just relax and put your attention directly on the sense base.
So when you go for a meal, and I'll remind you of this when we go for lunch, you see, as soon as you put your food on the tongue, there's always that comparison.
This isn't curry.
This isn't pizza.
There's always that.
Oh, this is wonderful.
See it?
So you let all that pass, all that pass, you put your attention directly on the tongue, and you're back to being a child.
You're back to being a person who can directly experience what's coming from the body.
Okay?
And that's the beginning of our practice.
All the time, all the time, to come back to the body.
The body offers us its sensations, its feelings, it offers us moods and emotions as felt sense.
Hmm?
And by drawing ourselves into that, leaving thought alone, then we begin to have these deeper insights into our nature.
And before no longer time, we will surely be liberated.
The scriptures, they talk about so-and-so having listened to the word of the Buddha, went away into the jungle and forest to practice, and in no length of time became fully liberated.
and the commentarial gloss is after 25 years so it's a gradual process a gradual process very good so I can only hope my words have been of some assistance may you by your fierce practice liberate yourself sooner rather than later